[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
berlins welt ich hatte vor ein paar
jahren mal eine schnitte gemacht und das
war auch oder ist bis heute sogar noch
monats lieblingsorte
und das ist schon ein paar jährchen her
gibt es auch noch auf einem kanal
aber ich dachte mir irgendwie wir müssen
mal eine schnitt orte 2.0 machen also
lehne ich diese torte heute an meine
schnitt worte von damals an
ich will aber wissen moderner gestalten
vielleicht ein naked cache mal schauen
ich habe hier noch nicht so ganz
entschieden jedenfalls habe ich damals
nie wieder master gemacht heute rechnen
für kuchen er das ist bisschen einfacher
und ich zeige euch jetzt die zutaten wie
stab mit dem kuchen und danach geben
richtung füllung und creme und dann
entsteht die torte einfach so wären de
bug prozess ich verwende für den
rührkuchen 4 150 kommt ca eine prise
salz etwas wandel extrakt und ein paar
tropfen bittermandel aroma 200 gramm
butter milch 200 gramm butter 130 gramm
mandeln und hier habe ich dann noch 300
gramm ihren und zwei teelöffel
backpulver das erste was machen werde
ist ich habe hier die mandeln bereits
fein gemahlen ich meine ja auch immer
gerne selber weil sie dann einfach viel
aromatischer schmecken und die könnt ihr
jetzt noch intensivieren also das aroma
intensivieren minute jetzt in einer
pfanne röstet ohne fett jetzt einfach
auf mittel hohe stufe dann immer mal
wieder schwenken und dann so lange
resten bisher einfach lecker durften
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich hier
drüben schon mal die eier verrühren
diesem schönen zimmer waren so lassen
sie sich super aufschlagen mit salz und
zucker mit etwas vanille extrakt ich
weiß gar nicht hatte ich damals schon
mal ein extrakt ich weiß nicht ist echt
schon lange her
tamandl aroma ihr könnt auch wenn ihr
wollt stadt bittermandel aroma amaretto
nehmen dann nehmt ihr einfach bisschen
von der buttermilch weg und fügt
amaretto dazu weil man einfach dadurch
diesen typischen mandl geschmack nochmal
hervorhebt und die masse wird so etwa
fünf bis sechs minuten
es kann auch sein dass in dem
handrührgerät zehn minuten rühren müsst
einfach verrührt bis sie schön weiß
cremig ist und die mandeln da drüben
nicht vergessen und den ofen schon
vorheizen auf 170 grad ober unterhitze
[Musik]
die
ich habe jetzt hier noch die butter
geschmolzen
also nicht heiß werden lassen sondern
wirklich nur schmelzen so ist perfekt
dann kann ich hier den partnering schon
mal einschlagen der film 20 zentimetern
durchmesser und der teig ist halt eine
rechtspartei
das legen von reichen
[Musik]
dann kann ich jetzt hier die butter
milch dazugeben und jetzt seht ist
wirklich schön luftig dann die mutter
mit rein
ihr könnt auch öl nehmen aber butter
kurz einrühren
und dann kann ich schon mal das mehl mit
dem backpulver 7
[Musik]
also mail dazu trieben nicht mit
backenbart haben die abgekühlten mandeln
dazu und alles vorsichtig unterheben
[Musik]
noch 30 sekunden müsste stellen sein
ja
stille post ab jetzt
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach den teig hier ein film
hintergrundkulisse egal die männer ich
denke sie nicht mehr stimmt ich krieg
sehen nicht mehr stimmt und da kommt der
kuchen in den backofen später aber
richtig stäbchen grobe lacina abkühlen
und dann geht es mit der füllung weiter
ok jungs jetzt könnte rede und
ausflippen
der kuchen ist jetzt schon abgekühlt
jetzt kann ich ihnen hier herauslösen
ich habe ihn auch gerade kurz in den
kühlschrank gestellt und damit dass ich
gleich einfacher schneiden ist also hier
einfach mit seinem tortenring messe den
rand lösung das backpapier öffnen und
runter wegziehen ist einfach umschlage
[Musik]
und dann den ring entfernen und einmal
pausieren
[Musik]
perfekt
der kommt kurz zur seite und dann geht
es direkt an die frucht füllung
ich hatte auch damals eine frucht
füllung mit himbeeren und kirschsaft
diesmal habe ich es noch kirschen mit
rein und bindet das ganze mit agar agar
also mit einem pflanzlichen geliermittel
ich nehme für die füllung 300 gramm
kirschsaft etwas ak 50 gramm zucker eine
haltestange bis hin zu thronen abrieb
300 gramm kirschen aus dem tk und 400
gramm gmbh aus dem tk es gebe ich den
kirschsaft in einen topf und ich habe
jetzt hier kirschsaft von kirchen aus
dem glas die habe ich jetzt in den
kühlschrank gestellt so weiter verwenden
neben aber die kirchen aus dem tk weil
sie einfach eine schönere farbe haben
als ich mich dass es schön richtig rot
wird ja noch mein aka aka dann zucker
und 17 stange und etwas zitrone abrieb
[Musik]
kkk müsst ihr einfach nur beachten dass
er den masse gleich aufkochen lassen und
dann muss es zwei minuten lang sprudelnd
kochen damit einfach schön wirken kann
die alternative dazu wäre gelatine ich
könnte ja auch nehmen aber ich bevorzuge
es hier einfach die pflanzliche variante
dci entferne ich dann nach dem kochen
denn jetzt kann so schön ihr aroma
abgeben und dann nehme ich sehr aus wenn
ich jetzt zimtpulver nehme dann habe ich
dann später dieses dieses pulvrige also
in der frucht belohnt das schmeckt mir
da jetzt nicht so gut deswegen wirklich
schön mit der zimtstange einfach würzen
nicht zu lange drin lassen die torte
zuletzt nicht weihnachtlich werden
sondern einfach nur so ein hauch zimt
eben dazu gewinnen
sobald es hier kocht
dann auch wirklich die uhr stellen denn
die zwei minuten sind wirklich super
wichtig und ich kann jetzt hier schon
mal den tortenring um den boden legen
also ich bin schon noch da beiden naked
cache zu machen und ich probier's mal
folgendes das kenne ich aus konditorei
nämlich sehr dass man auch gerne torten
rand folie benutzt um später den rand
wirklich ganz sauber weg zu bekommen
das machen wir jetzt heute hier mal denn
ich glaube dass das ganz gut ist für den
effekte nicht erzählen möchte und die
folie dies auch wirklich super stabile
könnt ihr auch mehrfach verwenden ihr
seht ja auch ich habe hier die kleineren
schon benutzt habe es einfach wieder
abgewaschen zusammengerollt und innen
rein gesteckt da nehme ich jetzt die
zehn zentimeter hohe stelle dann den
ring außen herum zum stabilisieren eben
ja immer mal rühren
fertig nämlich hier die zimtstange
heraus die können der theoretisch
einfach abwaschen und dann nochmal
weiter benutzen und gebe jetzt hier die
kalten früchte rein
dadurch kühlt die masse eben auch schön
schnell ab die himbeeren mitteilen
und jetzt die maße auch gar nicht so
sehr gesüßt denn die frucht füllung
dafür nicht immer ganz gut wenn die
sonne bisschen säuerlich bleibt und wenn
dann die creme einfach schön süß ist und
dann passt alles perfekt zueinander was
ich jetzt machen werde ist eine kleine
probe philipp brucker heißt ich nehme
teil von dieser flüssigen masse geht es
in den kleinen teller und den stelle ich
jetzt kurz in den kühlschrank und wenn
der innerhalb von einer minute ungefähr
fest wird weiß ich die masse wird fest
und kann sie weiter verarbeiten
wenn ich jetzt sehen würde die wird
nicht fest dann sollte ich noch mal
etwas gaga dazu geben nochmal schön
aufkochen lassen und dann eben weiter
benutzen
die wird super fest das gebe ich jetzt
noch mal mit rein und du kannst es
nochmal schön auflösen und dadurch dass
ich jetzt diese gefrorene früchte reihen
gegeben habe ist die masse auch nicht
mehr als das heißt ich kann dir jetzt
hier direkt auf dem tortenboden verteilt
schön sauber arbeiten des naked cache
werden soll also den rand im besten
falle nicht vor spritzen
[Musik]
und jetzt sofort verstreichen
dass es überall schön glatt ist gaga
wird nämlich super schnell fest also
ganz anders als gelatine hat natürlich
vor und nachteile
also eigentlich bei der kühlsten ist es
ein vorteil bei der verarbeitung muss
man sich einfach bei allen da sich
danach aber auch vorteile so jetzt
stelle ich die torte in den kühlschrank
und kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal
die creme machen denn wie gesagt aka aka
wird schnell und fest für die creme
nämlich 500 gramm mascarpone 250 gramm
quark etwas vanille extrakt 80 gramm
puderzucker 400 gramm sahne und etwas
seiner tat ein bisschen aus den unfall
aber ist es nicht
die zutaten hat heute nicht die sally
gerichtet ich weiß nicht was auch mit
der user kann es nämlich richtig gut
ich sag's nicht wer es war ich sag's
nicht
ich sag nicht wert die mascarpone in
dieser form gebracht hat erfahrt ihr
nicht mascarpone und quark sind jetzt
hier in der schüssel dann kommt das
vanille extrakt dazu puderzucker kurz
cremig rühren
und jetzt gieße ich hier langsam die
sahne dazu
was man natürlich immer machen kann ist
die sahne steif schlagen und dann
unternehmen aber ich hab mir das
irgendwann abgewöhnt also irgendwann
habe ich mir gedacht warum eigentlich
wir schlagen jetzt einfach
zusammenstellt und lustig und sobald
sich alles vermischt wird noch salat
oder säfte zu geben und schönen steif
schlagen
[Musik]
das habe ich hier den kuchen die torte
da gebe ich jetzt etwa ein drittel der
creme drauf schön verstreichen
[Musik]
und damit jetzt daran und auch schon
sauber ist nämlich ein
aber ich habe doch ein bisschen
gekleckert und kann jetzt ihr den rand
einfach nur schön säubern jetzt hier den
kuchen drauf also den zweiten
tortenboden und der schmerzmittel
gerissen
hoppala macht nix da hat diese werbung
aber das finde ich jetzt nicht schlimm
also dann hat er halt in der mitte
sondern kleine kuppe aber ich nicht
ehrlich
in krümmel reingerutscht
schon durch einen kleinen blick hier
rein es hier werden
es ist ein kino aus niesky ja jetzt das
zweite drittel der creme
sie belege ich jetzt übrigens gerade im
on also ich überlege jetzt gerade wie
die torte aussieht habe ich hab mir
gedacht
die recht creme nehme ich dann will sie
einen spritzbeutel und macht so spritzt
von grau und hier wieder schön glatt
streichen das ist eine glatte oberfläche
hat wenn es im glatt streichen übrigens
nicht so ganz funktioniert also nehmt
einfach diese tiefe tortenring palette
diese streich palette setzt die an und
dreht dann einfach mit der pfalz mit der
dreh platte geht es halt echt perfekt
weil da muss man echt nicht so wirklich
viel machen
ansonsten könnte auch einen kleinen
crashkurs besuchen beim maurer eures
vertrauens der kann das auch
ich glaube maurer könnte nicht die
besten dort machen schon so spachteln
stuckateur betrieb ein stück in dem
stück leichter da noch machen schon
nicht schlecht jeden rand wieder säubern
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisserl ein wirbelwind
gemerkt ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt
wir kriegen das besuchen daher dafür
soll die torte irgendeiner fahrt ihr
warum vielleicht geht die schere geht
nicht jetzt bin ich hier diese lochte
die hat 16 mm durchmesser fast und dann
kriegt ihr die spitze um kommt dem
spritzbeutel warum technik dann wird die
creme unten nicht ausläuft
die wird jetzt nicht auslaufen aber so
eine flüssigere die schon jetzt machen
eine schnelle deko die aber wunderschön
jetzt hier oben fest drehen sind
übrigens ein weg spritzbeutel aber die
könnt ihr mehr weg benutzen also die
sind echt zuvor stabil ich rate dir dann
auch einfach aus ob man jetzt drehte
hier oben einen spritzbeutel zu
diese hand die hat für den druck aus die
hand führt und immer darauf achten die
sahne dann nicht so weich zu machen
also hier drücke ich die creme raus hier
oben und unten für mich einfach denn
spritzbeutel schön senkrecht halten also
nicht so denn dann bekommt ihr keiner
schnellen spitzen und dann las ich
glaube ich schon bisschen rand und mache
hier so kleine tupfen darauf komplett
auf die ganze torte
[Musik]
und dann hier oben wenig creme drin das
wirklich die creme runter ich noch mal
schön fest und dann hat er immer den
perfekten druck nämlich auch auf die
torte
[Musik]
torte ist erst mal fertig kommt in den
kühlschrank bei mir sogar einen
gefrierschrank weil es schneller geht
und dann werde ich sie gleich
herauslösen mit bc mit so kleinen pc
stückchen die kommen dann optimal wenn
slow motion okay ich mache es dann so
wir lösen den ring später die folie
bleibt dran
wir richten samstag an es kommt pc
stückchen die werden darüber gegrübelt
mit glitzer schnee bestreut und dann
können wir die torte probieren das ist
doch mal ein plan
[Musik]
die
habt ihr das gesehen wie der schnee da
so drüber gefallen ist und dann habe ich
noch blitzer schnee drüber das sieht man
jetzt über die kamera nicht so gut aber
in echt sieht man echt cool so murat du
darfst probieren ja woran erinnert sich
diese torte
vor drei jahren war es gemacht und war
lecker ist meine lieblingsstrecke ist da
steht heute an die erste aber nicht an
unseren hochzeitstag ja hab ich jetzt
nicht schlimm aber lektorieren und ich
kann mich ich kann die emotionen mit
puppen und wir haben es sogar auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt damals meist auch noch
leere laufen lassen dann immer das
messer sauber machen damit der anschnitt
schön sauber ist dieser wir sind größer
aus als ja ich hab dir jetzt moderner
gemacht hat damals die war es ob es ein
klassischer und moderner naked case of
magic ist nichts schlimmes das ist die
abda die torte es merkt ja so sieht er
aus den anschnitt also bisher die sich
selber machen können jaja ich weiss
nicht besser machen genau die
spitzigkeit noch zu der probier mal und
muss ich ein bisschen was drin ist ne
was ich musste also einmal so durch so
alle alle bestandteile zusammen und die
heißt zwar schnee dort aber man kann sie
schon noch im sommer ist sommer herbst
jahreszeit loben
hammer wie möglich gehen ja das war auch
einer der meistgeklickten videos
ich habe ein bisschen verändert damals
eher sowie nasser heute zum rührteig
auch gut also falls ihr die torte nach
machen wollt dann findet ihr das rezept
in meiner sallys welt app oder auch
salehs - blog.de probiert ja auf jeden
fall mal aus gerne diese version oder
auch die alte version die ich damals
gemacht habt vor 45 jahren ich weiß es
nicht
müsste ich selber noch mal nachgucken
und dann könnt ihr die bilder gerne
posten und ich schau her einfach nicht
nur langsam essen ich mal einen kaffee
dazu ist somit bis auf jeder party bist
du schon mal auf jeden fall und vor
allem hat er gesehen mit dieser torten
rand folie bekommt man eben diesen
tollen effekt dass sie wirklich richtig
schön glatt wird außen
man kann sie dann noch mit der folie
mitnehmen und die folie auch wieder
verwerten also nicht wegschmeißen wir
werden sie auch gleich auswaschen und
dann hab da etwas wunderschönes und den
schnee vielleicht auch kurz vor dem
verzehr traum auswaschen
vielleicht und den schnee so kurz vor
verzehr darauf geben damit die b&c
stückchen noch so schön knusprig bleiben
den kuchen mit danach langsam wird
teilen disteln
für die nummer heran
[Musik]